i get i get a
i get a message i get a message from a
guy saying hey did you see this guy that
did the parody of you i said what are
you talking about what parody um listen
i've seen a lot of parodies
they've done a lot of parodies of me
they make fun of the accent they make
fun of my look all this stuff
but i actually thought this guy did a
great job when
uh the reaction i get from uh uh kai
comes up to his car says hey pat
he said this and he shows me the first
15 seconds i said stop stop it right now
i said i like the stuff he's doing i
want to watch the whole thing let's do a
reaction video and respond to him so
this is my first time watching it
i've only seen the first 15 20 seconds
can we watch it and pause and or do we
watch
what do you want to do i see you want to
go through it or you want to pause it
i actually want to pause it a couple
times kai what do you think i think
okay then go through let's see what he
says here go ahead and we'll comment on
it and we're off
okay you need audio for it to work guy
okay
first of all you're always clean with
your suits i don't know why his uh
collar's under yeah
we'll see what he's doing here but we'll
see
most people only see the final product
most people the successes the great cars
the honda crvs
is the hardships the long years of
struggle the rejection
the knocking on doors and being held at
guns he's got guns
let me explain stop explaining things
get out of my face man okay but say
something cut it out okay actually
explain did you go set up for the next
mafia interview
you were actually interviewing a real
made man
yeah have you seen goodfellas
because i i freaking love that movie do
you love that movie
when i was a young man we were ordering
the bottles
patrick uh how do you double your money
how do you make that happen and i said
let me ask you a question
and they say you got the white t-shirt
he's missing the gold chain though
by the way go back this is so funny the
way he's uh he's
uh doing uh how i uh explained the
interaction
go back in a few seconds this guy i was
a young man we were ordering the bottles
a lot of people ask me yo patrick
uh how do you double your money how do
you make that got the accent he's
actually a question
and they say well patrick i asked you a
question first and i said you know tag
you're it now
what are you going to do and so they say
well fine if you're going to force where
do you have your hair all messy rather
than yourself
i guess i'll do it good that's good to
hear so basically you got one guy making
250k
you're making a quarter of a million
dollars a year how much
two hundred right there just go back go
back
right there
on i was asking you that's it right
there keep going buddy
siri what's 24 times 36 the answer is
864.
see see that's why college is becoming
obsolete well i sat my wife down the
other day look maybe we are committed
for life the court has to
so there's nothing we can do to come out
of it because there's no way you're
getting half seven things to do
right one is marriage take your time
with marriage so i told my wife listen
baby we gotta keep looking good
we have to keep looking good because
oh here we go this sniffs here we go to
sniff you cold do you want a tissue
no no i'm great i'm just i'm just
letting my enemies know that i'm a
competitor you know
people to know it's supposed to startle
you sharp inhale through the nose the
sniff
you see it in the animal kingdom all the
time the king gorilla will just
kick her and i'm like oh my god what is
wrong with you i mean what do you mean
let's talk about that you worry about
your game
executing on your plan there are
actually uh
six areas i want to discuss with you
guys life that you've lived first the
story you know the story of
being a good fella i was thinking maybe
you and i we go in and we make a new one
called great fellows what do you think
you know
painted to be in the movies of course
you know i'm very lucky that i got out
alive so you're being a bit of a [ __ ]
right now
let me explain to you let me explain to
you what i mean you're a [ __ ]
okay he's about to try the ball number
one goal as an entrepreneur
right so basically you need to ask
yourself who is afraid who is
literally terrified for the health for
their lives for the family
and then how can i make money off of
this person you might think that i found
that
let me explain let me explain to you
what i mean oh you think i'm funny no i
never said that like funny how funny
like a clown please don't get into this
the gangster life is not real
you got an income problem thomas and
that's why
thomas do you love
boom peanut butter friendly
what happened kai a big thank you to
magic spoon for sponsoring this video
what is this magic spoon story
it is oh really okay is it was it
canadian
all right so good for him by the way
nailed it
no i like what he did uh
his name is what sinbad what's his name
captain sinbad captain sinbad
great job good for you watches
valuetainment once
watches valuetainment once and does this
so there you go i commented i said
i haven't seen it yet but the reaction
will be coming soon pbd here's a
reaction video so you got it funny by
the way
you know last night we were at the house
and you guys are sitting there watching
this cracking up
and this is your second time watching
this but last night we were watching uh
adam watched john mason's uh reaction
video
years ago have you seen that one john
mason did a good one i've seen many of
them but
nine years ago yeah he was he was
hilarious when he did that as well john
john can do me better than i can do me
is how good he is with it
okay all good well sinbad uh you're
hilarious
i just realized every time moving
forward i sniff i want to be thinking
about you just so you know we have a
relationship for the rest of our lives
with this sniffing situation okay so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye